Serena Williams stunning pregnancy pics
plus her pal Drake's got a Iran hot new
lady
and Pretty Little Liars departs after
seven seasons and so today we are in
mourning
thankfully I look great in black
this is the daily denne denne director
here I lost count on how many days has
been that Beyonce and jay-z have not
debut the twins in fact I think we have
an actual shot of me from this morning
if you guys can just roll that in real
quick oh yeah that is me I am dying
twins where you ask not while the babies
are in hiding Serena Williams is baring
her baby bump and a whole lot more the
tennis superstar posed for Vanity Fair's
August issue wearing nothing but a thong
and belly chain and it is gorgeous
that hits newsstands on July 11th and
inside the mag Serena opens up about the
surprise pregnancy and how she told her
fiance reddit co-founder Alexis Ohanian
get this
she took a total of six tests to
convince herself it was true and then
put them all in a paper bag and gave
them to Alex who of course was thrilled
by the news now
Serena is due in September and says she
will return to tennis as soon as January
because quote I don't think my story is
over yet and thank God because her story
took an interesting turn yesterday as
she put the grand slam on fellow tennis
legend John McEnroe after this dish on
NPR you say she is the best female
player in the world in the book best
female player ever no question what
qualified if she played the man sir
could she be like 700 in the world uh
let me remind you McEnroe serena has won
23 grand slams she of course fired back
tweeting dear john i adore and respect
you but please please keep me out of
your statements that are not factually
based respect me and my privacy as i'm
trying to have a baby
good day sir of course McEnroe didn't
quite back down today when he stopped by
CBS this morning
no apology did Serena really I'm listen
I would be happy to apologize arena yell
if that makes you feel better okay okay
well it's alright Serena just stay
gracious this revenge is your paper all
right of course Serena is happy and love
and life but remember we all try to blew
her up with Drake well drink isn't doing
too shabby himself these days in fact he
stepped out with a new lady on his arm
at the
the a Awards the rapper hit the red
carpet at the event which honors the
best of the best in basketball his red
hot date by inside that NB c-- sports
reporter Rosalynn gold on one day
Drake kept her close wrapping his arm
around her and later he posted this pic
to Instagram riding my stunning date for
the evening it's unclear whether these
two are actually an item but this was
not the first time he's been crushing on
Roz check out this Instagram from 2015
it's the two of them after his hometown
team the Toronto Raptors lost to the
Golden State Warriors he captured that
pick when the post game makes you forget
about what happened during the actual
game
alright we're keeping our eyes on you
two meanwhile somebody else is loving up
on Drake's and that's Justin Bieber he
took to Instagram to declare that Drake
is quote more than a rapper a culture
shifter and legend best of our
generation alright well from vest of a
generation to the end of an era
after years of twists turns unanswered
questions torment tonight Pretty Little
Liars will finally reveal the identity
of ad during tonight's series finale now
if I'm being honest I've not watched a
single episode of the show and that's
why we've got our resident TV expertly a
Megan Lara oh my god it's coming to a
head of your honesty Jenny control I
need your help girl we need your help
talk to me you've been covering this
show since the very beginning I have
talked to the cast through this season
right Avengers of my life are gone what
has been their general reaction to the
identity of a baby what's so exciting is
that every single cast member that I
have talked to this past season has
described this finale as iconic they've
loved it they're saying that the fans
are going to be so pleased with it which
makes me so happy because as a fan
myself I want to be happy with this
ending because the Harrison alleys are
so tricky to do and the least we'll know
how and you don't mean like everything
will come to a nice little close let me
are we going to discover who ad it is
we're going to know the why and the how
which is more important I love it
now besides a DS identity what else can
we expect them tonight's episode can
expect a lot because it's two hours you
guys oh my gosh we're going to be
getting a lot of flashbacks to fill in
those missing pieces a lot of familiar
faces returning to Rosewood
the moms are finally out of the basement
and of course we're going to just be
getting a lot more answers I love it
we're do the least they could do exactly
alright so obviously it's very emotional
that's ending and the cast has bonded
like no other what's been the reaction
to the fact that this is all coming to a
close they are sending out so many
bittersweet instagrams and tweets today
this is such a close cast you know they
all got matching tattoos together and so
they're actually all going to be
together tonight tweeting and connecting
with fans from the very last time this
is one of the shows that actually
started live tweeting all those years
ago well I know you'll be tweeting
tonight as well
she's also catching up with the series
creator Marlene King tomorrow
breaking down the last episode on e
t--'s rosewood rundown you can catch
that tomorrow on ET Facebook page man
thank you so much love you I'll see you
guys in row sequenza buddy all right
before we sign off there's so much
friggin TV to watch this week last night
there was more man drama as usual on The
Bachelorette
but Rachel kept it real for more on that
welcome back our bachelor nation queen
lauren zima
you guys in slithering in like a snake
and I'm gonna explain why okay Lauren
you have ten seconds on the clock
to recap us on this week's Bachelorette
are you ready ready go here's what's
amazing last night we had two hours and
Tuesday night there's two more hours you
guys it was the snake showdown between
Lee and Kenny and Brian emerged as a
front-runner you can check it all out
MPC online calm and please watch rows
and rows a ret YouTube Rika that's it
Lauren though with Josh you're doing a
gross okay now you do have your own show
so get gone gotta buck it but inside you
guys head over to e t--'s YouTube
channel and catch a road full
Bachelorette recap and be sure to hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel so
you don't miss an episode and until
tomorrow i'm gonna dance my way out of
here you know the deal okay